après 28 ans de pots de fleurs et de
carreaux blancs superstar de la
superstar dollars jean-pierre red hot tu
as dit à l'école on m'avait appris à
soigner les fleurs mais pas les empêcher
de mourir je décidé d'éviter de faire de
nouvelles victimes en remplissant des
pots de fleurs et du ciment
[Applaudissements]
oui
d'abord il faut que je dise que j'ai
fait des études d'horticulture
donc je devais être jardinier
offert du paysage des choses comme ça et
c'était le moment de la guerre d'algérie
c'était en 59
bon j'ai fait deux ans et demi d'armé et
au retour vraiment j'ai décidé que la
nature c'était terminé pour moi alors je
suis resté un an
allongé sur mon lit on va à lille on m'a
nourri finalement je voulais absolument
plus bouger et un jour je me suis levé
au bout d'une année et j'ai descendu
précipitamment dans mon garage un peu
poussé par une forme de deux pulsions et
j'ai trouvé dans ce garage un pot de
peinture rouge un pot de fleurs et du
ciment et c'est ça le commencement
j'ai mille six morts dans le pot je les
ai pas en rouge et j'ai senti à ce
moment là que j'étais sourire donc j'ai
commencé à revivre et j'ai commencé à
naître
j'avais 23 ans j'étais très jeune et
j'avais besoin de de vivre l'art un peu
comme une aventure romantique
certainement ce qui est peut-être plus
intéressant c'est que ça fait 28 ans que
je remplis des poteries heures avec du
ciment
et tu mets des souvenirs sous le ciment
des toits non alors parfois je glisse
c'est un peu des bouteilles à la mer
parfois dans le ciment je mets des
messages ou au début je mettais mes
poubelles je remplisse et les pots de
mai détritus et je mettais un petit mot
dessus et par la suite j'ai envoyé des
messages comme ça j'ai fait des
certaines personnes ont peut-être cassé
leur pour un jour et on était peut-être
un peu surpris de voir quelque chose
qu'ils ont compris au pas compris
c'était ma façon de communiquer avec
l'extérieur
mais c'était très instinctive tu les a
exposés ou cpo alors je les expose et en
allemagne à düsseldorf
j'en ai mis 400 l'un à côté de l'autre
et je les vendais le prix d'un pot de
fleurs chez le fleuriste personnes en a
acheté et amuser un peu plus avisés à
rapide ça vous combien aujourd'hui un
pot-de-vin peau à fleur pas en rouge ça
vaut ce que le marché veut bien en
donner mais d'une façon générale 30
mille francs
en fait toujours 28 ans déjà je crois
que je le ferai encore pendant peut-être
les 25 ans qui moi c'est à dire l'état
n'a fait inquiets qui est très grand qui
est la fondation cartier à jouy en josas
qui mesure trois mètres cinquante de
diamètre qui est pas en doré qui est
sous une serre oui j'en ai fait un
recouvert de feuilles d'or et j'avais
fait un projet pour l'arabie saoudite
qu'il n'a pas été réalisé encore et dont
la hauteur était de 30 à 40 noeuds donc
de toute façon pour moi le ya plus
d'échelle pour les peaux plus les peaux
sont grands et plus c'est moi qui ai
raté
donc il ya toujours ce rapport j'en ai
fait des tout petits qui font un
centimètre et demi que j'ai trouvée au
japon parce que les minières et rendre
tout miniature voilà et
non non ça j'ai vraiment trouvé quelque
chose de fantastique et l heure après il
ya eu l'histoire de la maison j'ai
décidé que
que je pouvais plus cohabiter avec le
monde extérieur et j'ai décidé de faire
une maison qui était une forme de
blockhaus et je me suis enfermé dedans
c'est la celle saint cloud où on se sent
et c'est une maison qui est entièrement
recouverte ces deux maisons qui étaient
là étaient pleins d ouais les portes
étaient teintées il y avait une forte
rigueur et j'étais très heureux a lancé
un bunker quoi c'est un viol et c'est au
premier degré il ya toutes ces
expressions comme ça il ya toute cette
expressionnisme mais je pense que
derrière il ya aussi un terrain qu ont
défriché qu'on labour est bon
aujourd'hui j'ai plus les mêmes
fantasmes mais je reste totalement
fidèle à moi-même et jours dans la
maison
j'habite absolument la maison je les
ferme et la dernière pour vingt années à
bon parce que j'étais envahi par deux
cent mille personnes sont riches vers
10h au début quand iolas voulait montrer
ta maison ils fêtaient un autobus pour
amener les gens voir la maison des
pierres prêtes à vêler bateau qui venait
la voir le dimanche quoi un peu que
j'avais j'avais les badauds mais j'avais
aussi les chartes heures qui venaient
des états unis de ce rallye du japon et
par tous parce que ça c'est le problème
des télévisions et
et des médias plus en plus on en montre
est plus fort montré alors au bout de 20
ans j'estimais que j'avais donné et j'ai
cassé le nez cassé le truc et j'ai
décidé de me donner 20 ans doit lui
toujours dedans mais on n'a plus droit
de la visite est ce la solution
je vais il rentrait tout à l'heure et et
je le vrai en 2008 mais quand tu rentres
dedans des fois tu ne dis pas que tu
voudras habiter ailleurs que non c'est
pas dire est-ce que c'est pas devenu un
espèce de rituels une espèce de de
fidélité à peut-être plus qu'à ton image
met en oeuvre et que tu préfères
réhabilité comme tout le monde dans un
appartement ou normal
non je ne veux absolument pas habité
comme tout le monde mais par contre dire
que c'est facile ça n'est pas facile
mais de toute façon moi j'ai choisi mon
destin depuis très longtemps j'ai
divorcé il ya 25 ans pour pour vivre
avec cette maison j'avais choisi déjà
j'ai décidé que je n'aurai jamais
d'enfants
j'ai décidé que je vivrai seul
définitivement donc il faut que j'assume
aussi tout ça alors que je sois
prisonnier de mon image ça c'est pas
contestable
3 que toute personne qui qui est
égocentrique fonctionne avec son avec
l'entraînement de son image mais à ce
moment là il faut créer une règle du jeu
il faut y trouver son compte
il faut sentir les points d' équilibre
et il faut avoir surtout une un très bon
équilibre psychique
ça va ça marche ça marche on doit
continuer à travailler la céramique tu
as fait un jardin à monte carlo
deux mille mètres carrés en céramique tu
rêves de faire une cathédrale
tu devais faire une synagogue et chicago
je sais pas si je rêve de faire une
cathédrale lâcher de la synagogue et
chicago qui voulait bien le faire on m'a
dit tu vas là faire peur en fait
certains projets arrivent
ne se font pas d'autres se font manger
un très beau projet sur lequel je suis
depuis huit ans et qui je pense va se
réaliser dans deux ans qui est le
recouvrement d'une des tours des
minguettes
fenêtres murs une des tours qui est mûr
et finalement qui ne servira plus jamais
et qui sera complètement occulté par les
carreaux de céramique sur les portes sur
les fenêtres et qui sera un peu la
mémoire du lieu
alors ça c'est un beau projet parce que
la tour fait 50 mètres de hauteur et il
ya vraiment des gens qui ont vécu à
l'intérieur qui ont qui ont souffert ou
qui ont été heureux et je vais
travailler sur du vécu et c'est quand
même un objet qui ne sera pas un objet
rapporté
c'est un objet de la mémoire les gens
qui sont à côté connaissent cette chose
et je vais simplement venir apporter mon
élément
en fait tu travailles pour les
archéologues du futur quoique ils vont
déterrer des pots de fleurs qui vont
regarder ce qu'il ya derrière ces
céramiques non ça me déplaît pas jeu ça
me déplaît pas l'idée de me placer été
très critiqué très détesté on m'a pas
pris au sérieux parce que je crois qu'un
type qui fait des pots de fleurs toute
sa vie on ricane c'est normal et qui
emploie des carreaux de sanitaires qu'on
trouve dans l'est dans les toilettes et
dans les abattoirs
c'est pas très sérieux mais en fait je
fais ça depuis 28 ans je crois que dans
le domaine du travail quand un ouvrier
fait son boulot pendant pendant 28 ans
on le respecte donc voilà alors de la
même façon moi je demande que après 28
ans de remplissage de pots de fleurs et
de hêtres carrelage ombre et spec c
était influencé partie mondrian non
j'étais influencé je prends par personne
au début parce que c'est mon instinct
qui m'a poussé c'est ma pulsion mais
j'ai des attirances comme tout le monde
et mais je ne suis pas influencé je
crois que klein est un des plus grands
artistes de la deuxième partie du xxème
siècle c'est certainement le le pilier
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord mais ça
j'en suis convaincu mais je peux aimer
des choses très différentes
je peut m'intéresser à l'histoire de
l'art mais j'en suis pas victime d'une
maladie du bien sûr bien sûr parce que
c'est quand même une dimension de
l'absolu c'est pas d'art qu'il s'agisse
et c'est le sait le dépassement de
l'homme pendant donc c'est là le
déplacement de l'homme ces larges et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu